hello everyone sorry about not posting
any video yesterday I was with my chess
team we're playing a chess match and
this is my game from yesterday it's a
very interesting game I had the black
pieces and well I was really feeling
great and I wanted to attack so let's
see how that went and my opponent was
white and he played d4 Knight to a6 c4 I
played g6 Knight to c3 and Bishop to g7
I decided to go for the Kings Indian
nice to have three I castled and my
opponent played h3 I've never seen h3
played in this position before so I
didn't really think much about it you
know I was expecting efore and then I
would well continue with d6 but okay he
played h3 and now probably I should have
gone for d5 as he did allow it by night
not not playing e4 but I played d6 like
I'm playing the normal King's Indian now
if you play d4 and I played Knight to c6
kind of provoking d5
he played pawn to d5 and I went back
Knight 2 g8 something that I often play
because the wall no one really managed
to take advantage of this tempo as of
yet
my opponent played Bishop to d3 and I
played rook to e8 preparing to push my a
pawn
White Castle Knight B to d7 and rook to
be one my opponent decided to get this
rook away from a1 from this long bishops
diagonal and also he's preparing to push
b4 to play on the Queen side I played a5
to you know stop his expansion and he
played rook to e1 now may be preparing
to push a 5 himself at some point so I
played east 6
he played Bishop to e3 I played he
capture some d5 see characters on d5 and
while here I played nice to h5 I always
enjoy having my night on h5 when playing
the King's Indian that way this Bishop
comes alive I'm also controlling f4 and
the wall my idea is to exchange this
night by playing Knight - if
and then maybe maybe put this Bishop on
e5 and then the bishop and tonight we'll
be controlling f4 but okay
my opponent played Queen to c2 which I
didn't really think it was a good move
I thought maybe Queen to d2 was better
to try and you know exchanged the dark
square Bishop Bishop to h6 and that well
maybe at Sun control to the f4 square
but okay
he played Queen to c2 I played Knight to
e5 as planned he captured I played
Bishop captures on e5 and I really liked
my position here I'm really controlling
f4 not allowing him to push it for
himself and well here my opponent played
night to b5 and well this comes with a
threat of Knight captures on c7
obviously forking both of my rooks and
while here I do have a couple of options
for example I can protect it with rook
to e7 I can even push c5 maybe for
example if he plays D captures on c6 on
Poisson I I can sacrifice a pawn here
and well gain some activity threatening
Bishop to d7 and after he retreats with
the queen wall here I have options of
Bishop to b7 Bishop to e6 Bishop to e6
maybe even if I feel like I can
sacrifice on h3 but I didn't do any of
this I decided to play well an
interesting move I played Queen to h4
immediately going for the attack and the
well inviting him to capture the pawn on
c7 and if he captured the pawn on c7 I
would capture the pollination through
with my bishop and Weldon depends on
what he plays if he plays G captures on
h3 I would have played a rook a to C 8
now pinning his knight and while his
Queen would be stuck defending that
night and oh well I I like my position
here and if he didn't capture it for
example if after Bishop captures on h3
he decided to grab the rook then I well
I would have played something like
Bishop to g4 now threatening all sorts
of ideas and after for example g3 Knight
captures F characters and Bishop
captures well again I like my position
for example Quinta gee do I have Bishop
to h3 Queen f3 now capture the night
well a white is better here I mean by
the engine but it's a complicated
position the White King is well wide
open I I would enjoy playing this but
after I play this Queen to h4 move my
opponent didn't grab the c7 pawn well he
played King to f1 with the idea that
well after I sacrifice the bishop he has
this e 2 square as an escape route for a
skink and I didn't really expect this
move and this really came as a shock I
mean I thought Knight captures on c7 was
was definitely gonna happen but okay he
played King to f1 and here is probably
where I could have played a better move
for example Bishop to d7 and what black
is okay for example rook to e7
protecting c7 would also be fine if he
captures with the night I can pin it
with the other rook well a lot of moves
would be okay here before would be a
perfectly good move but as my opponent
really surprised me with this King to f1
move I really you know tried to
calculate something out and I well I
played a towel move or so I thought
not Bishop captures on h3 I played a
really weird move I played Bishop to h2
now not allowing his king any retreat on
g1 and again inviting him to capture on
c7 with ideas well probably if he
captures I will sacrifice my bishop and
then begin some sort of a king hunt and
in this position my opponent actually
offered me a draw which I declined I
really liked my position really liked
well it was a very very intensive
gameplay so he did he kept he captured
Knight captures on c7 and I played
Bishop captures on h3 and here I thought
he would capture G captures and h3 and
if he did that I would play rotate the
c8 again pinning the night and again I
like my chances here but after I played
Bishop captures on h3 he
and capture the bishop he immediately
captured my rook honey if he played
Knight captures ne8 and well again this
move also came as a shock to me because
I thought that he had to grab the bishop
because I mean they're simply too much
attackers on the Kings side I thought
this was this would be winning for sure
and well I thought about a lot of things
here for example I thought about Queen
to g4 now after Queen g4n threatening
Bishop captures an G do with checkmate
but the problem is after G captures on
h3 I have to play Queen to f3 and not
allowing him to escape with King to e2
and the wall I thought that this was an
okay position for example he can't
really kick my Queen away from there if
you play something like Bishop to e2 he
gets going to h1 with checkmate but the
problem is in this position he has this
well a very nice resource of playing
rook eat the c1 now making an escape
route for risking with King to e1 and I
don't really have anything here I can
grab the night and well this King is
running but he's running to safety so
white would be perfectly okay here so
after he played Knight captures and he
ate I didn't play Queen to g4 I played
Bishop to g4 now well with ideas of
moving this bishop and of course
checkmating my opponent with Queen to h1
as now this Bishop is stopping the King
from escaping with the e2 move and well
he can't play something like g3 because
Queen to h3 is checkmate
and also he can't really play f3 he gets
Knight to g3 with check King to f2 and
now his king is stuck on f2 he can't
really go anywhere
I simply capture the night on e8 and
well he can't really capture my Bishop
here if he captures that he gets Queen
to f6 check Bishop f4 only move and
Queen captures on f4 with checkmate
so after this Bishop to g4 move hidden
played g3 or f3
he found the best move he played Bishop
to e2 and well here my troubles
art it's a it's not that easy to find a
move for black now or how to continue
this attack probably well I considered a
lot of things well for example I don't
know Bishop to d7 so you know if he
captures my knight on age five I will
recapture and then I have this Bishop to
b5 check maybe but none of these moves
really led to anything so I simply
recaptured on e8 captured this night he
played Bishop captures on g4 and I
played Queen captures on g4 and here he
played Bishop to h6 well not allowing my
my work to get into the game because
well my my last rank would be really
weak if my queen ever moves he would
check made me for example with Queen to
c8 and well in this position I played
rook to c8 and this wasn't a very good
move I I thought I had something here
but the better move would be to play
Bishop to have four immediately force
him to trade this strong bishop on h6
and after Bishop captures Knight
captures on f4 I would be threatening
checkmate on g2 and after a move like f3
now the Queen is defending G to play
Queen to h4 now threatening Queen h1
check and then after King moves to have
to capture on g2 and while he would have
to defend with Queen to f2 and I could
capture King captures and all night d3
for king the king and the rook the King
moves
I grab the rook rook captures and what
the material is equal his pawn structure
is a bit better but you know where this
game is this games continued you know
we're still playing this game nothing is
over but after a bishop to h6 I played
rock the c8 I had an idea which proved
to be faulty
he played Queen to d3 and here I played
Bishop to f4 and now I thought that
after this Bishop is exchanged I will
somehow be able to bring my rook into
the game with rook to c2
he played Bishop captures and i-4 and
now the problem
well if I capture Knight captures on f4
he would have this Queen to f3 move and
after Queen to h4 he does have g3 a
queen to h3 check and King to g1 and
here I have no way to continue the
attack my knight is attacked I have to
move it somewhere only place I can move
it to is a h5 and after he plays the
rugby to c1 my attack is completely over
so after he played Bishop captures an f4
I played Queen captures and I for I
wasn't really satisfied with this but
you know what are you gonna do I had one
more option of actually playing Queen
captures on g2 with check and now after
he captures I can capture the bishop
with check and now after he moves the
King grabbed the Queen and after I'm
like rook to e3 and 95 he would be up
the exchange but at least I would grab a
pawn so even this was better than what I
played but I wanted to keep the Queen's
on the board as well I thought this was
my only option
so after Bishop captures on f4 I play
the Queen captures on that four he
played Queen to e3 and here I don't
really have a lot of options here maybe
the best move was Queen to e8 I played
Queen to h2 my idea
well now that I would like to play
Knight to f4 here but I was in time
trouble I didn't really have time to see
my opponent's next move he played Queen
to h3 and now I have to exchange Queens
if I don't he grabs the rook on c8 yeah
so much for that rook the c8 idea so I
grab the Queen to play G captures on h3
and after Knight to f4 he played Roxy
one I of course don't want to exchange
rooks I played rook to e8 and after up
the c7 well both of us have six bones
but he is out of the exchange and in the
end he managed to win this this ending
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and well there's I'm sure
there's some sort of a lesson to learn
from this game you know don't play don't
play at all move for no for no reason or
or if you're not really
anything and well I did have a couple of
chances to get back into the game but I
just wanted to continue my attack and in
the end this was my downfall so yeah I
do hope you enjoyed it again sorry about
not posting any videos yesterday I was
really busy I would like to thank Robert
mm afford hands for hire
Martin Wilbur clay Waddell and Tony Maud
guitar for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here I thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon